[Music]
hey everyone its Peter Brown with
GameSpot here and the game we're going
to show you today is simply called echo
this pretty captivating looking game is
from ex hitman developers they've
started a new studio called ultra ultra
and this is their first game since their
studio started now the important thing
you need to know about EKKO is that at
first glance it's very confusing and
even if you watch a lot of gameplay it
might not be easy to understand what's
going on the core conceit is that you
are trying to explore environments that
have cycles between light and dark now
within these environments are clones of
your character and it's up to you to
either kill them or avoid them to reach
an objective the trick here is that
anything that you do while the lights
are turned on in these environments it
could be as simple as walking through
water eating food as firing your gun
pretty much any action you take other
than simply moving will be recorded and
the clones in the environment will then
mimic what you've done and understand
what you've done
the next time that the light cycles off
and then back on so again that means you
do one thing during one light cycle and
it's picked up by AI for the next one
[Music]
and the difference between the two
cycles is the dark that comes in the
middle anything you do in the darkness
which is also when the a eyes memory is
wiped from the previous round
anything you do in the darkness again
the AI cannot pick up on so you're free
to do whatever you need to do to get to
your objective but the darkness only
lasts for about 10 to 15 seconds so
you're gonna spend most of your time
pretty much going up against yourself
both because they're clones
that you're fighting and because they
are essentially using your capabilities
against you based on what you've already
done it's kind of a confusing game it's
definitely very good looking and even
sitting with the developer who you see
now playing the game it can be very
tricky but you can even be very
difficult for someone who knows what
they're doing so we'll leave you to it
this is echo the game is coming out
hopefully next week it's currently going
through the final certification
processes and you can watch for about
the next five to ten minutes and watch
essentially what happens when you're put
up against yourself again this is echo
by ultra ultra and if you want to see
the review stay tuned a game spot and be
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I could see was yours from here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a few more to go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]